what if a filmmaker tells you well we
just want to launch this campaign and
make a movie we're not looking to like
spend six months trying to build you're
going to fail I mean you're going to
fail unless you have you know the only
way that that works really and is if
again I talked about earlier about
building up social currency well it's
the same thing a building up currency as
a creative you know there's a reason
that the Veronica Mars movie or zach
braff you know they can go out and put
something up and have to get funded
right away because they have this
currency with the you know with the
world I guess you could say the online
world but people they have fans you know
they built up this base right some
filmmakers I know some filmmakers who
have made some shorts who really really
cultivated relationships the whole way
through and crowd-sourced always through
and then hit their goals and then when
they come back to do the second movie
it's a little easier ok when they go to
do the third movie it's a little easier
because they keep these people and keep
everybody involved that entire crowd but
I've also seen and this happened this is
actually going to make it into the book
where a same exact example where you
have a your first-time director who
really work social media raised i think
it was ten thousand dollars for short
everybody got a copy who donated you
know everybody loved the guy you know
you went to do the second one either the
same thing again great went through the
third one did even better he want some
festivals and everything and also they
got big hat and he said well i could
just throw it up now it was a year
between now he's going to do his first
feature he needed a little bit more
money and he so i'm gonna go right back
to the crowd of course they're gonna
support it but he threw it up he didn't
engage he didn't all of a sudden he
became I'm he liked his tweets became
I'm here and I'm there and I'm off doing
this and you know it became like you
know like a Gump kind of thing like he's
you know hobnob in here and I'm gonna
and nobody cared nobody cared anymore it
became now you want because everywhere
every ask got bigger like the Rays got
bigger and he ended up not making it and
now he's struggling to get money for his
next short you can't I just can't stress
it enough that you know it really
especially when it comes to the
crowdfunding it all comes down to
relationships and it all comes down to
building those relationships and keeping
those relationships even you know a mile
mile and a half
day okay the film premiere two years ago
to this day they are still engaging
their audience they are still putting
videos out and just updates and saying
hey guys you know we're hiking this this
weekend like what are you guys up to
like that kind of thing it's you know
there's something to that again you feel
ownership you feel connection and and
that's really what it's all about it's
crowd funding you know it's crowd
sourcing it's moving a crowd it's not
moving an individual it's not yelling at
an individual so I'm making demands of
an individual it's identifying engaging
and moving a crowd so with the other
filmmaker who was not successful was at
the third or fourth time at what time
what did this time with a feature yep it
wasn't more of an expectation and I
don't have to do the dirty work or a
story was ego in you Burruss it was it
was this idea that you know they
supported me the whole way through and
you know he forgot how hard it was to
get to where he he got to as far as
getting that crowd to follow him and now
he had kind of turned his back on the
crab because he was saying he wasn't
releasing a video every other day or a
tour going to his you know followers and
saying how you doing or this is to what
the movie is about here's a clip from
here's you know here's a scene like some
people like we'll take two pages of the
script and say here's a little teaser
what we're looking to do what do you
think of this some people like oh it's
really really cool maybe you should
change my character's name for this
weather but you're engaged you're
involved he wasn't doing any of that
instead he was saying well now I'm in
Paris and I'm talking to this guy and I
and people will like you have a whistle
here like you know like you know don't
go all the way up here and not like you
know you're not giving us anything like
you're not engaging us anymore you're
not keeping us involved anymore and if
you're going to crowdfund I don't care
what you're doing if you're going to
crowdfund and I don't care what kind of
success you've had you do have to have
that element still you have to keep
people engaged you have to make people
feel like they're a part of it don't you
think people want to see that quote
unquote Instagram life a little bit
though like so they can kind of
vicariously live through but not if
that's the only thing you're doing like
this became you know it's a case study
on how not to do things it became
instead of you know it wasn't just the
Instagram life it wasn't just like hey
you know
here I'm here like I said like gonpa
Zelig or whatever it was Sophie here so
be there like you know what I mean like
living you know hashtag living large
like you know it's like you know that
kind of thing and people you know people
gotta tune you out and you're done you
know this the next thing and it's the
next thing and there's the next project
I could throw my weight around the next
one you know I could do it right she's
me I could donate to the next thing
right so he didn't become he wasn't
appreciative any more anime almost
rubbing in people's faces a little bit
yeah but he's the biggest thing even if
it wasn't so much at me you know maybe
he was appreciative maybe he's still
have rich but he wasn't engaging gosh he
wasn't connecting you know everything is
about connecting you want to feel
connected I mean it's the same thing
about being its same thing being a fan
of somebody really if you think about it
I mean if you you know people are fans
of celebrities because they feel that
they either you know to see the respect
thing or there's something some sort of
connection they feel like they mirror
their values or you know he's a great
guy and you sit there and go Holly and
always a great guy you saw him in a
movie but you know but it is a cute guy
it's cute but there's a connection in
their mind as a connection and when you
sever that connection you know you loose
bits why it's why some movie stars you
know are up here for the longest time
and then they fall down it's not always
just age it's just or you know tap
sometimes it's just a disconnect you
know what I mean and it's certainly that
way when it comes to crowdfunding and
crowdsourcing it's it's n social media I
mean again it's the same thing you know
the people that get the people that
organically get a lot of likes or the
people that if they're not celebrities
to people that you know the people to
get a lot of likes a lot of followers
are the people that engage they're the
people that you know aren't just out
there like I said broadcasting they're
out there posting great content and
talking about and asking questions about
it or taking somebody else's comment
content and saying well you know what
compelled you to write that what
compelled you to do that that's really
interesting to me thank you for posting
that it makes a difference you know me
it really really does it's certainly no
different when it comes to crowdsourcing
and crowdfunding
you